Did you sign something so that Manny could
switch to French?
I did.
You knew that I wanted him to learn Spanish.
I also know you can't force a kid to be
interested in something that he's not.
That's why I have a picture of Mitchell and his prom
date shaking hands.
It would be nice for someone to care what I
think, for a change.
You should also know that I hired a new
swimming instructor.
But don't worry, she's got the same broad shoulders
plus a mustache.
So all this is because you're jealous? I
can't believe that you're being so infere-
What is the word?
Selfish. Pigheaded.
Really?
Her words, not mine.
Do you know how frustrating it is to have to
translate everything in my head before I say it?
To have people laugh in my face because
I'm struggling to find the words?
You should try talking in my shoes for one mile.
I think you meant-
I know what I meant to mean.
Do you even know how smart I am in Spanish?
Of course you don't.
For once, it would be nice to speak to someone in
my own language in my own home.
Listen, I'm sorry I let Manny switch over to
French without consulting you.
I didn't think how it must be for you having to speak
English all the time.
You have no idea.
Anyway, I just wanted to tell you I hired a
tutor back.
Manny's not going to like that. He's too
much into his French thing.
The tutor is not for Manny. It's for me.
[Speaks in Spanish]
Ah Jay, I love it!
Now you sound like the stupid one!